i'm i'm in a feud
i'm in a hip-hop feud i'm a hip-hop dude
and i'm in a hip-hop feud
that's why i say don't push me bro
but he wants to push me busy bone wants
to push me dude
he wants to push me this is not the
[ __ ] link
one fire put the link on the thing and
this is not the link
he wants to push me though baby
busy bone
wants
he wants smoke and it's fine and look
here's the thing dude i was a big fan of
bone dogs and harmony way back when and
i think i talked let me just let's break
down this where's this video dude let's
get this video i may have to cut because
i need to get this video and [ __ ] of
course one fire send me a video of a car
video this works on the thing
okay let me get it
why did it start with a car
did i click the wrong thing
let me do it right now you're going to
want to hear this part pardon me dude as
he said to me part of my [ __ ]
interruption you're gonna want to hear
this dude
oh i don't know why it had a different
thing here we go all right dude here it
is bone thug's in harmony member busy
bone so here's the deal i told a story
on the [ __ ] podcast a while ago and
it was about how i was at the comedy
store with my brother and faison love
all right you might know him from friday
we were hanging out talking and in the
middle of the conversation busy bone
walks up to us
and wants to say something to faison
love now he says pardon my [ __ ]
pardon the interruption pardon the
interruption didn't need all that we
were like whoa whoa what the [ __ ] is
going on yelling and screaming poured in
the interruption pardon the
[ __ ] interruption pardon my
[ __ ] interrupts kept saying it
must have said it 12 times told the
story on the podcast said he didn't need
to interrupt that art didn't know what
it was i hope that he's all good wanted
to talk to faison love
talked to faison love a little bit
walked away and that was my whole
experience with busy bone all right now
it was on some hypno hip-hop news
outlets for a little bit and it said
crystalia talks about busy bone of
course the media ran with it like
crystalline is talking [ __ ] about busy
bone but that's what happened don't know
what busy bones saw
don't know how he took it cause again
not uh mentally there who is though not
me
who is though no hate on busy bone think
he's very talented in 1999 and that's
fine
all right the one issue i had with both
dogs and harmony is everyone was they
had 95 songs about how everyone was
trying to rip bone thugs and harmony off
and these bone clones were out there
trying to [ __ ] jack their style when
it's like huh
there was nobody like them and there
never was and that's why they were
[ __ ] awesome
for three years and then warren's now no
hate
there's still bone [ __ ] out
there that want to be out there and be
like you know i mean dude honestly when
they said asan giving up for chatta for
cheesy food god's got it i felt that
[ __ ] dude
right
when they said it
got it and i'm gonna miss everybody and
now that's when i was sat back and i was
like you know what these lyrics actually
mean something to me
so
say what you want they got a fan base
and i'm all for it dude
but like i say in the hat don't push me
i said what i said because it happened
with no hate but he wanted to pardon the
interruption and he did and we let him
talk to face on love don't know what he
said because after that i was astonished
and my brother and i were looking at
each other like wow and i said is that
busy bone and my brother said yeah and i
said that's crazy
so now busy bone goes on this [ __ ]
thing streams live and starts talking
[ __ ] about yours truly me
and now as a 19 year old when i was
listening to [ __ ] bone thugs and
harmony listening forgot got it gonna
miss everybody on now
apesam
listening to listening to it in tim
chung's forerunner as we're going to get
[ __ ] jack-in-the-box at lunch period
right
i never thought that i would be this 42
year old man still young as [ __ ] spring
chicken a little bit of salt and pepper
but it's nice right
and i've got beef with busy bone
and this is what he says in his video
man i wrote some stuff about tupac and
tupac said i don't know about him
i said well that [ __ ] still holds true
today then the [ __ ] just started
bucking on tupac okay here we go yeah
but he's a
this man i dm the dude special i said
the house
the house
what the hell did tupac do to you okay
here we go
what did pop do to you were you even
alive when pop was alive here we go what
the [ __ ] did he do come on yeah
okay so that you know that's that's just
let's get
down
to the real [ __ ] okay cool
by the way thank you for calling my [ __ ]
the real [ __ ] i don't know what it was
before that i didn't watch the whole
thing but he was [ __ ] he was doing
some [ __ ] stuff i guess but this is
the real [ __ ] okay great
all right i gotta stand up for this [ __ ]
oh he's bad he's mad at me
this is real i
in front of the move three comedians
y'all and i want y'all to pay close
[ __ ] attention it's been three
comedians that has in
specifically in specifically
now i i honestly and specifically did do
that so
or busy bomb okay and jim
okay
first of all we gonna deal with chris
the [ __ ]
[Music]
of middle school
chris
the [ __ ]
dude
oh that's a song give it a vagina for
these things for god's got it come on
man
i ain't gonna say your whole name whole
ass [ __ ] they know it's me and
i'm not a whole ass [ __ ] they
know it's me and they know me dude and
you know something about me i'm not a
hoe ass [ __ ] dude so here we go
dude we're on we're on dude i'm i this
is
oh all right let's listen and have a
listen to this whole thing yeah cuz i
wanted to do with you guys
so chris the [ __ ]
running with it dude i'm not a ho-ass
[ __ ] busy bone dude you want to
smoke
i'll perform in cleveland no bulletproof
vest
says he supposedly met me yep
at sun show my show i was supposedly
this
a-ho no you were not an [ __ ] you just
had pardon my interruption 19 times
didn't understand what was going on and
it was not at some show it was at the
comedy store here we go okay first and
foremost
when i'm in my zone
cool
man i can't have nobody around me great
so you were in the zone when i'm about
to get on stage wait a minute dude what
okay
but you're not a comedian so what do you
mean when you're about to get on stage
were you playing a house of blues no you
weren't because it was already
demolished by that time across the
street from the comedy store so let's go
electric okay and these people have paid
for a show right like the people at the
company like that hold on i ain't
drinking i'm smoking you know i'm none
of that like i'm focused like all right
let's get these people the best show in
the world baby come on oh he must be
talking about ways
you know your lines your boys know
exactly where you're breathing at the
show is perfect you just make sure you
do the right stuff cool don't do too
much don't do too little blah blah i
mean that's what's going on in my mind
okay that's good you trying to come up
to me
and and like before the show yeah and be
like
hey man how are you man i mean i am in a
zone we finna get crazy up here
he
did he listen to the video dude
on the thing on the on this podcast i
said it was at the comedy store it was
my show he either saw it or he didn't if
he didn't then don't talk about it but
if you want to smoke dude
i'm going to give you four free tickets
to any show you want to come to come
come actually you know what i'm going to
give you 20 free tickets come with all
of the bone thugs and all the bone
clones dude
we could talk this out
so you ain't gonna really get no
conversation that don't make me an a-ha
you came up to me
it just don't i'm not a young blood is
better from trying to cap and think i'm
not gonna answer you right away bro i'm
not gonna give you what you asking for
i'm gonna get to you later no i'm just
gonna give it to you later i mean i mean
made it up all in his head you gotta
understand with somebody in the zone i
was in the zone it was my show uh i was
talking to faison love he is on the show
too
and i had fail
it was my show if anyone's in the zone
i'm in the zone dude
don't twist it like you're in the zone
you weren't in the zone then i was in
the zone and you were interrupting me in
the zone
somebody and they craft and they
mastering they crap man they're not
trying to joke
i'm not a comedian i mean like i'm lost
i'm not here to play i'm ready to
explode on this [ __ ] stage my
man wow so that's the first thing so he
got all on his little website he got a
little i got on his website
60 years old dude god on his webs are
you talking [ __ ] about me on your
website
got all on this website you know what i
mean uploaded some videos to funny or
die checked out ebon's world you know
what this [ __ ] got on there man
he went on aol got in some chat rooms
started talking [ __ ] about busy bone
you know it's low you know it's no
podcast there you go you know i got it
bro
you know i got a podcast that does
stupid numbers you know dude stop hiding
behind this [ __ ] on my website i don't
have a website too you can get merch
there but come on dude i wasn't talking
[ __ ] on my website you know what it is
it's on the critically acclaimed
congratulations podcast dude whatever
hell you talking about yeah you know
busy
[Music]
don't call me that why don't nobody say
nothing about flesh that's my only
question
why don't nobody always come to the
light skin [ __ ] man god damn i gotta
always fight for my lou
i think he's having fun with honesty
okay cool i like that i ain't gonna keep
going on and on about that but you know
it would be nice if you really felt some
kind of a way
dm me i don't feel seen you
it's not what happened
so now i'm in a [ __ ] beef with a hip
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude
chrisley.com goddammit i'm gonna beef
with the [ __ ] dude now i have a
[ __ ] hip-hop beef
[ __ ] dude
get these at chrisley.com
[ __ ] dude god damn it it's a new brown
one you get chrissy.com [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] [ __ ]
periwinkle one you can get chrisley.com
[ __ ] god damn it dude
i can't believe i have a [ __ ] hip-hop
beef now
sorry guys
[ __ ] jacket for the fall get chris
later come on [ __ ] god damn it
[ __ ] dude this is the new one i [ __ ]
my favorite one dude just [ __ ] the
wife rips puffy one it comes out it's a
bad [ __ ] christmas god damn it dude
i can't believe i have a hip hop beef
just because i told a story about how
[ __ ] busy bone goddamn [ __ ]
because busy bone [ __ ] what do you
call it he [ __ ] interrupted me and
faison love dude
just trying to hang out with my brother
matt can back it up faison probably
can't cause he was high as [ __ ]
am i in a beef with faison now too dude
also dude man
you know
like i appreciate what you did for hip
hop man
i like busy bone and i like that he's
having fun and i like that he's kind of
doing it what is this a podcast or
whatever the [ __ ] i don't know what it
is but i like that he uses the he's got
an elliptical back there so that's cool
man he's trying he's good for you know i
mean i know he wants to be hardcore but
also he's into his health so he cares
about living you know how like rappers
like i don't give a [ __ ] i ain't afraid
to die you obviously are afraid to die
if you have a [ __ ] elliptical okay
because you're trying to stay healthy
that's all
so pardon my [ __ ] interruption
but
um
[Music]
crazy
crazy
[Music]